y estamos transmitiendo en directo desde
los alrededores de la oficina nacional
de procesos electorales nos hemos movido
hasta este punto de la ciudad donde se
registra una marcha de protestas de
seguidores de pedro castillo tanto en
lima como en cajamarca donde se
encuentra pedro castillo sus parciales
han dicho que ellos rechazan estas
proyecciones que han dado
la bota esa boca de urna el conteo
parcial la boca de urna que posiciona a
keiko fujimori con el 50.3 por ciento
el sufragio y a castigo con 49 puntos 7
asimismo pedro castillo ha publicado en
el twitter que él llama a los
simpatizantes a movilizarse en las
calles del perú pacíficamente para
defender los votos y asimismo hace un
llamado a sus simpatizantes para
defender la democracia
cuál es el rechazo los simpatizantes del
pedro castillo consideran que él viene
representando la mayoría de votos de los
electores en todo el perú y no reconoce
en este primer lugar que hasta el
momento parcialmente tiene keiko
fujimori estos resultados parciales son
la boca de urna no son los totales no se
puede decir que ganó keiko fujimori y
perdió el pedro casi o porque hacen
falta el conteo oficial de los votos que
reciben la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales va a ser a las 11 y 30
la noche esta situación se ha venido
mostrando lo que ha sido esta campaña
una campaña política de ambos candidatos
que ha polarizado al perú y este como
venían señalando algunos analistas
políticos con los cuales hemos estado
conversando a lo largo de toda esta
jornada ellos dicen que esta situación
del resultado de las elecciones no le va
a brindar la estabilidad al perú que
necesita que ha venido atravesando
diversas crisis sino va a continuar
porque siempre va a existir una
situación en la cual ninguno de los dos
candidatos va
hacia ti si va a ser las ansias lo que
es él
resultado de las esperanzas de sus
simpatizantes siempre haber va a haber
un descontento por la opción que pierda
precisamente en cajamarca donde pedro
casillas se encuentra en estos momentos
pero estos simpatizantes han dicho que
rechazan estos resultados previos y que
esperan que los organismos oficiales no
tengan esta tendencia porque si no van a
continuar con una protesta masiva en
todo el perú francés francisco hablemos
un poco de las bases electorales no de
keiko fujimori y de pedro castillo no se
considera que castillo tiene más
electores no en lo que es el sector
campesino de las afueras de las grandes
ciudades y de la capital y más mientras
que keiko fujimori muy famosa por su
apellido un tema que más adelante en
este plano especial vamos a estar
analizando tendría mucha más base de
voto en lo que es lima la capital y las
grandes urbes es esto así
si precisamente pedro castillo
representa al perú profundo son
ciudadanos que demandan un cambio un
cambio al sistema político al sistema
económico y por eso él tiene las
preferencias del poblador rural se lo
estaba acusando de ser un representante
en la izquierda radical y las
acusaciones han sido mucho más agresivas
se lo ha relacionado con el comunismo y
con el grupo armado sendero luminoso
pero esto ha sido todavía hasta el
momento y me hizo como
un rechazo una parte de agresión de la
denominada 'guerra sucia' que se ha
establecido entre ambas las candidaturas
presidenciales pues bien pedro castillo
viene según el conteo a boca de urna
viene llevando en mayor presencia en 18
regiones del perú donde este conteo
parcial de votos de las encuestadoras lo
posicionan con el 18 por ciento de los
votos
mayormente emitidos hacia él mientras
que keiko fujimori señalan que tendría
victoria en sólo 8 regiones del perú
esta situación establece que la de nuevo
del proceso electoral todavía va a
continuar la polarización keiko fujimori
por otro lado podemos decir que
representa la continuidad del modelo
económico y del modelo político ella
tiene el respaldo
en los partidos políticos de las
empresas privadas y grupos económicos y
no solamente eso sino también han
recibido un respaldo del premio nobel de
literatura mario vargas llosa así como
de otras personalidades
la candidatura de keiko fujimori no ha
convencido al resto del perú que en
estos momentos está dividido entre
quienes apoyan a pedro castillo y
quienes defienden lo que es la
candidatura de keiko fujimori hay una
situación en la cual los ciudadanos
mismos han señalado que no es que todo
el mundo quiera a pedro castillo y otro
tanto que era keiko fujimori sino que se
vieron obligados a votar por estos dos
candidatos que no eran de sus
preferencias